اعوذ مره اخرى الى الملف الذي كنا قد
بدانا به نشره الرابعه وهي حادثه همم
سلوان ظهره اليوم ومعنا من القدس مراسله
العربيه لانك الغازي لان مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض كانت لديك بعض
المعلومات بان احد من اصيبوا في هذه
العمليه عمليه همم سلوان هو ضابط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما الذي يتوفر لديك من معلومات
اضافيه حتى اللحظه الان
صحيح يعني حتى اللحظه هذه هي المعلومات
المتوفره ان احد فعليا الاشخاص الذين
اصيبوا هو ايضا ضابط في الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وهو اليوم كان في اجازه
وتواجد في بلده سلوان وطفل فعليا اطلق
النار على هذا المستوطن وايضا على
المستوطن اخر يعني تقول الاخبار فعليا ان
او تقول المصادر ان هذا همم ايضا المصاب
الاخر هو والد هذا الضابط وهما يعني
احداهم في همم فعليا حاله خطره والاخر
حالته متوسطته اذا اردنا ايضا ان نتحدث عن
الوضع في الميدان فهناك تواجد مكثف للشرطه
الاسرائيليه كما تحدثنا ان مفتش الشرطه
العامه الاسرائيلي قرر بان يبعث كتيبه
فعليا خاصه تابعه لكتيبه همم اليمامهم همم
يعني وهم كتيبه خاصه
اا اراد ان يبعتهم في الى القدس وتحديدا
الى القدس الشرقيه تحسبا وتخوفا لاي عمليه
احاديه الجانب همم فعليا من ال- اا الجانب
الفلسطيني في القدس
الاسرائيليه سيعقد مساء هذا اليوم همم ما
المتوقع من هذا الاجتماع الاقتراحات التي
يمكن ان يطرحها رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو على
طاوله الاجتماع مع حكومته وبعض الاقتراحات
طبعا كانت قد نقلتها اكتروس لكنها العالم
دقاتها من من عدمه
صحيح سوف يعقد في تمام الساعه الثامنه
مساءا في توقيت القدس هذا الاجتماع سوف
يحضره يعني عدد من الوزراء ااا
الكبار فعليا كبار الوزراء ايضا او كبار
الرؤساء عفوا في الحكومه اليمنيه سوف يعقد
ويعني لا يوجد امام اسرائيل خيرات او عدد
خيارات كبيره فنحن نذكر بان هذه العمليات
هي عمليات من اشخاص يحملون الهويه الزرقاء
الاسرائيليه وهم يعني لا يوجد لديهم ملفات
او اسبقيات جنائيه لدى السلطات
الاسرائيليه ففعليا هم يعني يتحركون من
دون وجود هناك انتماء لاي فصيله من
الفصائل سواء الفصائل في الضفه الغربيه او
حتى في الفصائل الموجوده في قطاع غزه
فيعني لا يوجد هناك الكثير من الحلول لدى
اسرائيل سوى توفير عدد اكبر من
الشرطه العناصر القوات الخاصه وفعليا هذا
ما قامت به منذ صباح اليوم وبالرغم الوجود
هناك استغفار وعدد كبير من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تم تنفيذ العمليه الثانيه ومن
قبل فلسطيني وهو طفل يبلغ من العمر 13
عاما يعني ايضا هناك غضب من قبل
المستوطنين راينا ايضا تواجد بينج فير همم
ليله امس في همم ساحه تنفيذ العمليه وايضا
تواجد اليوم في عمليه او في اساء او في
المنطقه التي تم تنفيذ فيها العمليه
الثانيه وهي في منطقه سلوان كان هناك غضب
كبير من قبل المستوطنين هم يعني تحدثوا
انهم اخطار همم اختاروا وزراء يمنيين
واختاروا شخصيات يمنيه متشدده همم تحمل
ايديولوجيات متجدده ويمينيه متطرفه ولكن
هم فعليا يطالبونهم بتغيير الامر الواقع
وتغيير الامر في الميدان ولكن المستوطنين
يقولون بان القدس ليست امنه للمستوطنين
بال وجود هذه الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه
طيب اريد السلك كذلك عن منافذ هذه العمليه
لانا يعني ربما انت تحدثت عن ولكن يعني
باقتضاض اريد السؤال هل فعلا تاكد انه طفل
عمره 13 عاما هل اصيب هذا همم الطفل همم
التحقيقات معه هل تم الكشف عنها حتى هذه
اللحظه دوافع هذه العمليه ايضا
فعليا يعني لم يتم الابلاغ عن دوافع هذه
العمليه ولكن كان هناك فعليا همم
اجره او اجرى الضابط الاسرائيلي همم من
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه ايضا تحقيقات
الاوليه مع منفذ هذه العمليه وهو فعليا
الطفل يبلغ من العمر 13 عامل ولكن لحد
الان لا يوجد اسم نهائي اا يعني متوفر
لدينا يعني لا يوجد هناك تصريح نهائيا
باسم هذا الطفل
اليوم يعني التي همم درجه
الحديث عنها في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التنفي على لسان همم
عائلته كذلك ايضا في موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لا اعلم ان كان هذا صحيح
صاحي لذلك لذلك لا يوجد يعني اسرع نهائي
لهذا الطفل هناك يعني معلومات يعني خاطئه
انجرت على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي نقلها
عدد كبير من ال اييي مستخدمين لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن لا يوجد لدينا حتى
الان اسم نهائي لهذا الطفل ولكن المعلومات
الموجوده لدينا انه يبلغ من العمر 13 عاما
وهو ايضا من سكان بلده سلوان ومنذ صباح
اليوم كانوا فعليا في حافله عموميه وقد
يعني نزل في شارع حي سلوان وكان مسلحا
ولديه سلاحا واطلق النار على المستوطنين
وهمم اصاب مستوطنين احدهما كما تحدثناه هو
ضابط كان فعليا في اجازه اليوم
الاخر هو كان والد هذا
المستوطن
وفعليا الفتى او الطفل همم يعني هو مصاب
وتم نقله الى احد المست في القدس اشكرك
جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي نقلتيها لنا وتنقلين هل
لنا منذ ظهر اليوم القدس مراسله العربيه
لناك الغاسي